another couple i wanted to ask you about
as well and i uh talked about it in that
uh prior podcast that you said that you
saw with uh
kyle and shayna and
on the show there was a
portrayal that this dude was like
simping for a girl that clearly didn't
seem to have genuine interest in him
um yeah what was going on behind the
scenes you know with those two beyond
what i had talked about on that um
feedback
yeah so
i know he appeared to be
like sing along like he said but another
layer to it
um
let me start by saying this every single
person on the show went on it to some
degree
looking for fame right i mean it's like
you don't go on a show less without that
in the back of your mind you know um
every single one including me you know
and and then hey i mean that's kind of
the point of the show one of the points
of the show but there's some people who
[Music]
really
did it for fame you know what i mean and
kyle is a perfect example of that
you know um
kyle
he's applied to like 20 different
reality shows you know dating and not
dating
um he he knew where he stood with shayna
but he's like okay like let's just like
try and see
how far we can go with this you know
okay just going along
um he's applied to several dating shows
since
the show has come out he's taken acting
lessons things like that
so like
that's that's where i stand with him
like shayna on the other hand i think
she felt something
for shane and
yes she did
accept the
the you know engagement to be on the
show a little bit longer i think she she
wanted it to get another chance at like
talking to shane and to be on the show a
little bit longer you know but for kyle
i think it's like a straight up like
like he would uh
i don't know like if if if that like
whole simp roll of his like were to
continue into like
all the way to the wedding he would have
just
rode that out if he could have
you know he has no he has no problem
with with looking that way if it means
getting the camera time
um
and and he's kind of on my [ __ ] list too
because at the reunion i'm not sure if
you recall but
he made this big dramatic phrase where
he's like
shake you you screwed up man
i could have
married deeps it could have been me who
got engaged to deeps
like he expected me to be like oh well i
was like dude just go marry her then bro
like go ahead
what's stopping you like you have you
have you know my my blessing and the the
thing that pissed me off about that
like i said less than a week ago we're
watching the super bowl right
why don't you tell me then bro
or the the 50 times we hung out before
that we hung out so many times between
filming rapping and then the reunion
being filmed
it's obvious he just wanted to save that
to be dramatic and like
kind of throw shade at me at the reunion
you know so like i lost i lost a lot of
respect for the guy
what did you learn about human nature um
between men i mean this is a two-part
question so
like
from the show and from your experience
you know post show obviously what did
you learn about
you know the nature between men you know
as friends because you obviously live
with the guys you know between the pod
sort of sessions and all the girls were
on the other side and what did you learn
about women you know the dynamics
between men and women
yeah um i mean that's
that's a pretty open-ended question but
you know i will say this
i think um
she's an interesting dude
the concept of group think is a very
very real thing
and um
you know the men who
had no problem like joking around with
me and like you know allowing me to to
be open with them and like even giving
me feedback normal constructive feedback
um initially
once the girls kind of got more
involved with them now they're like
spilling everything to the girls and
like you know these are
just just like you talk to your guy
friends when
you need someone to talk to and you want
some advice like imagine if those guys
like went behind your back and like
suddenly spilled all that to the girls
like that
some things are not meant to be heard by
the opposite sex right
um but in a situation like this i
honestly feel like
i don't know what the right word for is
you know you were talking about the
white knighting thing like that was in
full force that wasn't full full
especially
like this where
you know
the women are typically going to have
more of a you know
they're going to be featured more
they're going to become more famous
they're going to be
you know more prominent we'll say
so because of that like this white
knighting is like to another extreme
it's like oh okay i used to be on this
guy's side but now i'm seeing that this
you know the girls are being kind of
you know
they're more prominent they have more
influence so it's like
all right well i guess i'm on on the
girls team now
and and it's it's very obvious like for
the rest of the cast it's kind of like
what the girls do the guys kind of
follow along
like they're almost trying to like stay
on the girl's good side to be like you
figured out this stuff i think it's sad
bro i think it's just letting women lead
i mean i i don't think
i i i don't think from like a sexual
polarity standpoint but at all but i i i
think it's i think it's sad that like
these guys aren't confident enough to
kind of like make their own way for
better or for worse you know but i mean
isn't that the status of masculinity
today in the west generally speaking as
is you know guys are
becoming less so women can become more
they always defer to their wives i mean
it's why you hear this stupid lyric that
all these married nerds always
regurgitate over and over again happy
wife happy life right like these are the
same guys that will go to google at 10
o'clock at night you know when their
wives are in bed watching some stupid tv
show going how do i get my wife to [ __ ]
me sort of thing right
oh yeah yeah oh you're right you're
right it's uh it's pervasive and um
i'm not sure how we got this way and i i
know you kind of asked me before it's
like
how
you know what part of your childhood or
whatever like
you know when did you have the wake-up
call and i'm not sure i'm not sure it's
just it just
didn't really jive well with me i mean
my parents are happily married they're
they're great i i i love them both um is
your father the patriarch like the one
that led the family
yeah definitely i mean my mom she's also
like very
vocal and well spoken and all that too
but like in a good way you know what i
mean i i don't i don't see
i don't see any you know
mismatch there um
but you know actually now that i think
about it i i did read a book by corey
wayne are you familiar with him oh not
that one that's dude i gotta send you a
copy of my book okay yeah
okay so corey wayne so what happened no
i just want to say that that um
you know
as far as mindset
i did learn a lot from that book you
know and and it's
i i have to read your book still but you
know it's a good starting point it's
it's um
it's not going to get you to a three
percent man i tell guys it'll get you
like 30 percent like it'll get okay not
in the top for sure but yeah
okay well no just just the i this
there's an idea there where it's like
you know a man
follows his purpose and then you know
once you're following your purpose
everything else falls into place
including your relationships
right moth got blocked on instagram
but you know but that that that always
you know stuck with me it's like yeah
i'm gonna do what's best for me and then
like
i'm i'm driving this bus and like you
can hop on the bus and you can have a
great time or like if you don't want to
be on the bus that's okay but i'm not
going to hop on your bus you know i'm
not going to let i'm not going to let
you drive my bus
yeah
and and i mean the second part to that
was also like what did you learn about
the dynamics between men and women from
that experience on that show
um were there any big lessons for you or
ah the dynamics between men and women i
mean
i i think men are very visual creatures
i think that's that's gonna matter to us
like it always will matter to us look i
mean
there there should be maybe an
experiment where like
the
the men can't see the women but the
women don't know like anything about our
careers you know what i mean like like
you were saying because like the scale
is different it's it's not apples to to
apples really here um what what we
what we
judge or evaluate
uh women on is not the same as what they
evaluate us on
um i'd say that'd be the biggest
takeaway and and that love is not blind
man it's just not it's just not you know
like even at the end of the day if you
have like the best
best career and everything like how you
look is still gonna matter to the woman
definitely hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you